III feel involved with this thing called
identity server for quite a while and as
the name implies it's a server yeah and
I never really cared about clients but I
also completely appreciate the fact that
most people the only reason people bring
up a service to connect clients to it so
we have lots of customers that actually
write clients and and what this talk is
about is basically giving you an
overview basically of the things you
need to know when writing a client for a
token-based back-end and that is
typically open early connect and a wharf
ok this is not an introduction to open
early connect or Wharf otherwise we
would need two more days after this
session so the assumption is that you
kind of know what it's about and you
know and and you basically just get the
guidance that the digest if you like
ma'am so when you when you start going
out to the internet and and you know
like Google for how do I build a client
for my connect yeah you're gonna get
tons of links basically yeah and and
part of that reason why why you gonna
get tons of links and also maybe
confusing and conflicting information is
because it's complicated okay and one
reason it's complicated more complicated
than it could be is is that ooofff an
open oh bloody connect are maintained by
two different standards bodies okay
normally you don't use a Wharf on your
own on its own rudder or and you don't
use open re connect on its own it's
typically a combination of the two
protocols that make up a useful system
the problem is is that one is maintained
by the IETF and one is maintained by the
oh bloody foundation and you have to
basically piece together the information
from both websites into into one
guideline if you like okay so if I go to
these websites here and and transform
the content into this
it gets apparent that there are a
significant number of specifications out
there ma'am
I I recently saw that somebody counted
the pages of all specifications and it
was twice the number of pages than one
piece so it's a lot of stuff to read
okay unfortunately I can tell you I have
read them all
I guess so what this talk is about
basically is you know sorting out the
useful versus the not so useful stuff
okay so um so normally you know we talk
about the things on the right size today
we're gonna talk about the things on the
on the left side and we will make a
distinction between so-called public
lines and confidential clients yeah so
when you look up look into spec the
definition of a confidential client is a
client that can securely store a secret
and that for all practical means
typically means it's a server based
client yeah something that lives on the
server that is a you know secure in a
data center and you can store stuff
there ma'am
various the public line is exactly the
opposite of that it's basically
something that is well that cannot store
a secret securely because there there is
no good place to store it yeah like
JavaScript based applications or you
know like things that you install on on
users machines okay so we're gonna have
a distinction between the two so
generally speaking regardless of the
client yeah the requirements looks
simple right you get a token you use the
token there's the whole point of the
system when we look at the most simplest
flow in in which is called the client
credentials flow which is for server to
server based communication the way this
works is basically it is you have a
client that's this thing here you have
api's in your system and you have this
thing called the authorization server
which is basically the the token service
so when the client now wants to talk to
the API he doesn't send his secret
directly to the API he first goes to the
token server or authenticated a token
server gets back a token and from that
point on users to token to access the
API right that is the way it works
all the time in variations sending the
token to the API there's a spec for that
hour of c6 750 basically that the
recommendation is use the authorization
header in HTTP that's a special header
from the SEF you know from from an from
a security point of view web servers are
aware of this header that it will
contain confidential information they
typically don't lock these headers
browsers handle them in a special way
and so on so that's basically how you
send the token to the API so that's easy
but the hard part and that's probably
the the the biggest part of this talk is
what's happening in between after you
requested the token and before you use
the token do you have to manage those
tokens yeah so what you don't want to do
is for each API call get a new token
that would be very inefficient yeah so
so what the typical approach is is you
get a token you see you store it
somewhere you hold on to this token for
a certain amount of time and you keep
using or reusing their token to talk to
the API okay so there are many
approaches on how to do that you know
like maybe you're just storing it in a
variable that's good enough or maybe you
have like a real caching system a net
has the session storage system maybe you
have more you know like a vault for
example things like that a database
might might do as well and then there
are two general strategies here either
you just you know put that thing in your
cache maybe give that cache a lifetime
of token lifetime minus one minute or
two minutes or something like this and
as soon as the cache doesn't give you
back the token you get a new one cache
it again and and continue you think that
the other approach is called you know
it's more like you don't care too much
about the caching you just keep using
their token until you get back a 4 1 4 1
means well the token is expired
you get a new token you resend the
request so it you know it's it's
proactive versus reactive one of the two
you have to implement ok so in other
words the real challenges are requesting
the token well but which type of
protocol flow
we are using managing to talk and
storing them renewing them you know make
up your mind for how long you need to
access those api's and then you use the
token for that's you know that's how it
works okay so let's have a look at some
at some typical scenarios here yeah so
one is um one is or the most common
scenario I should say is basically you
have an interactive application you know
with a UI let's say it's an application
so you have a couple of jobs to do here
you want to authenticate the user first
you want to know who the user is you
want to probably start a session or join
a session like like a single sign-on
session for example you know there are
some other things here related to the
session like listening for session and
modifications and so on and then you
want to make calls to api's on behalf of
that currently logged on user and then
you want to manage the token basically
that for a lifetime this user is using
the application you know you are
actually able to call these api's
because they expire at some point and
you need to manage them so for that the
original o of specification has created
this thing called the authorization code
flow and the idea of the authorization
code flow is it's a two-step process the
first step is coordinating all of the UI
work and the second step is then getting
the tokens so if you know that the UI
work happens on them on the front
channel in the browser typically where
you go to the authorized endpoint and
you say okay I want to have access to
these things give me a code that
represents the outcome of this request
so that then afterwards I can on the
back-channel you know exchange that code
with the token that that's offer a
sation code flow and you know this is
not not an introduction to or from the
assumption is you know all these things
already okay so that flow was created in
the first place because it seemed to be
the most secure option right so if an
attacker could steal the code in the
browser then he couldn't turn it back
into a token because he's missing the
client secret for example for that you
know was that the original motivation so
to speak that this code represents all
the things that
happened in the UI and then the backend
with including that client secret and
can harvest the results so to speak
ma'am so that code flow is from 2012
that was really a wolf pack was created
it turns out attack us are you know they
they they have some good ideas and they
try to attack this protocol in a way
that nobody thought about it first yeah
and you know and this is called a code
substitution attack and the idea is this
yeah yes the application and the
attacker cannot turn that code into a
token because he doesn't know the client
secret but if I can trick the
application into turning a stolen code
into a token then well I don't need that
client secret because the application is
doing it for me right so the idea is
maybe I make proc click on a you know
install a malicious application for
example he looks in that returns the
code I'm stealing that code from him
then I'm logging into the real
application on the way back I just
exchange the stolen my code with the
stolen code and I'm impersonating proc
right so it turns out o of has no
mitigation technique for that now so the
original code flow is vulnerable to this
problem and there is no solution for
that in or of itself um that's my
additional specs exist and you should
use one of them one is more like the
open airy connect flavor of solving that
problem and one is more the or flavor of
solving that problem and it depends
which flavor your client library
supports ok so one of the two should be
him should be in there let's start with
the hybrid flow and what the hybrid flow
approach is doing is basically he adds
another token to it yeah but because
ultimately the problem why the client
cannot make sure that code is really the
code he was looking for is because he
can't validate it right but with an ID
token you can validate the identity
token and then inside the identity token
there is a special claim called the C
hash which which is the hash of the code
so in other words you first validate the
signature of the ident
touken and with that you can validate
the signature of the code okay and that
you know make sure that this code is
actually belonging to the identity token
and that means nobody has substituted it
okay so a spinner car is an example of
that where this is implemented for
example um yes it's been cool so when
you are using a spear core as a client
you are in a pretty good state because
they are client library is very good
yeah they support hybrid flow they
support all the crypto stuff it's it's a
good library we can you know I can
briefly show you that that that that's
the example of an agent core application
that's their opener you connect handler
you basically specify okay the response
type is code ID token that tells the
handle okay I'm gonna use hybrid flow
I'm gonna do all of the extra security
checks and that's all being done for you
okay
another thing that a spirit core does
has it has facilities for them for
managing that the tokens are making the
token management easier
I showed this demo this morning already
so I won't go into detail but basically
you can hook into the session lifetime
events at a spirit core and implement
your token management there so that your
actual business code doesn't need to do
this okay
and that's basically by you know
implementing a couple of events here on
this cookie authentication Handler and
one of them is called validate
principles so when the cookie comes in
we we look for the token in the session
we checked like is it about to expire if
that's the case under the covers we
gonna refresh their token exchange the
old one with the new one your
application code doesn't know about this
because you know it's it's all happening
kind of like in the pipeline okay did
the other thing you can do is which is
good hygiene and sign out time we are
actually revoking the token again right
because that's that's a good thing to do
as I said we don't have time really to
to go into all these details but all of
these samples are in our github repo and
I'll show you
Burrell later so you can play around
with that coach okay
huh there are always issues right so you
could think like okay piped flow is the
solution to the problems of why why do
we even continue thinking about this
problem it turns out that the solution
that Hybrid flow proposes is it's not
simple to implement okay so as I said if
you are if you using a spirit core then
you're in a pretty good shape
I have many customers that have to
integrate with other companies and they
don't use the aether core they use PHP
and Java and so on and turns out it's
not easy to find spec compliant hybrid
flow implementations outside the
Microsoft space because they do not they
tame that was there they they
implemented it but many other libraries
don't yeah they did it just stayed on
pure code flow ignoring the problem with
the substitution name so that's one
thing yeah it's it's harder to implement
the other thing there's another spec
that came after open D Connect is called
gdpr
you might have heard of that one as well
um since in hype it flow you are you are
sending an identity token you are
potentially leaking identity information
over the browser right because that's
the nature of the identity token
depending on how good your your subject
identify us are or bad how bad they are
you might leak identity information
about the user and that might get
flagged depending on who you're Chi DPR
consultant based yeah so the nice thing
about the code was that all you're
really sending over the front channel is
this random number and that's it there's
there's no information in it so to speak
but it's not good enough yeah and we'll
see a second technique in a you know in
a second okay let's switch to public
clients so for public lines we typically
deal with two fundamental types one is
native clients like a phone you know
phone apps or desktop apps and
JavaScript lines yeah so
when we when we look at public clients
um the rules are a little bit different
here so normally when we see
confidential clients there's a
one-to-one mapping between a client ID
and an and the instant of a software now
whereas with public lines basically you
know you're creating your mobile client
you give it a client ID you put it in
the app store on 1 million people
download it they all have the same
client ID ok so that's different um
there is a process called dynamic client
registration which basically is a way to
how you can turn a public client into a
confidential client and that is
typically done for if it's done then it
only makes sense for mobile I mean for
for for native apps and the idea is this
that basically you are putting your app
into the app store with a bootstrap
client ID and then it's downloaded the
first time you run it there's some sort
of user authentication happening that's
pairing that instance of the client with
some back-end you issue a new client ID
you issue a client secret and then you
have have a confidential client basic to
him but that is rarely done to be honest
em ok the good thing is if you're
building a native application then there
is actually a spec for that or you know
a spec is maybe the wrong word and they
call it the best current practice now
and it basically is a guideline if you
like yeah and again you see it's funny
they call it or for native apps and not
open addy connect for native F because
it's written by the IETF and nobody open
ID foundation but guess what all of the
reference implementations of that spec
they live on the github repo of the open
ID foundation and guess what they do in
their reference implementation they do
openly connect and not or fear so it's
all a bit silly apart from that this is
a very good document to read it's very
practical it's been written just a year
ago I think and it talks about you know
actual features of mobile operating
systems like iOS and Android and how to
use them to create better applications
so the first thing they talk about is
how you should not do things and that is
basically by using a native login page
ma'am so you know you're you need
all that you install the app it brings
up a native login page with name and
password and then you think like okay so
what are you doing with my password now
yeah is that is that secure or not I
don't know but generally speaking the
spec tries to discourage you from using
this flow here where you harvest
passwords in the front end send into the
token service right and then you stare
at the resulting token to to call the
API and to be honest in all fairness
this is much much better than it used to
be where the where the app just
harvested the password and just send it
over to the to the API directly right I
mean that's an improvement the problem
is you don't know how how good this this
developer was really ugh is he really
throwing away your password is he really
storing he's talking securely yeah I
don't know do don't do an experiment
yeah if you have an iPhone you can do a
backup of your iPhone and there are two
backups one is the application data
backup and one is the keychain backup
okay normally all your secrets should
only live in the keychain and not in the
application space now so and then
restore that backup on a new phone and
see how many applications you are still
signed in okay if you're still signed
into applications then their developers
they stored your secrets just somewhere
on the hard disk and not in any secure
location and they might probably even
have your password and and so on and so
forth so you know I don't I don't know I
don't like this approach but you know if
it's the first party application it's
hard to argue against it if you own the
front-end you're on the back end it's
you know it's up it's a business
decision typically what I prefer from a
technical point of view is this approach
where the where the client opens a
browser so to speak it it goes to your
already existing login page where you
have all your logic already in place
right you log in there and there are
techniques to transport the tokens back
from the browser back into your
application
the people we actually talk about these
techniques I can show it to you now just
to see how it feels so that's an iPhone
apparently so
Apple provides native API is to launch a
special browser it's a special process
specifically made for authentication
yeah it has a couple of features it it
is secured against the key logging for
example so the application cannot read
the keystrokes from that browser there
is some you know memory protection there
and you also get access to the shared
cookie container on the phone meaning if
you already have a logon session with
the the browser on the phone you can
reuse that logon session also from
within the application when I click that
and because it's a special API that is
only used for authentication purposes
Apple will tell you regardless of what
the application just told you that the
window that that will open now is used
for authentication okay and that's
basically a mitigation against you know
phishing attacks and and so on okay you
press Continue here then the browser
opens you have your login page here and
you know since this guy supports Google
and I already have a lock on session
with Google on my phone I think let's
try it
yep that works no no login page right
single sign-on
and then the tokens gets sent back to
the to the client application ok and
from that point on I have a refresh
token I can call refresh here right and
get it and get it get new access tokens
I can call api's and from from that
point on this application can run
independently and doesn't have to show
that browser again and again so that's a
pretty pretty good technique I think how
does it work basically by registering a
special redirect URI with the operating
system and when the browser comes back
to this URI basically what will happen
is is that the operating system will do
a callback back to the application where
is where this URI belongs to and that's
how you how you get back your code you
open the back-channel
get your tokens okay there's one more
thing
III mentioned that there's a second
technique to to a mitigate code
substitution it's called pixie a proof
key for code exchange and that's what's
being used here so basically what's
happening here is before the client
application opens that outgoing call it
creates a secret a random number
basically which is only used for one
single request and then then it hashes
that random number and sends it along
okay and when when it opens the
back-channel communication it's gonna
it's gonna send the clear text version
of that random number and what the
server's going to do then is it will
take the clear text version hash it
compare it with the hashed version you
got on the front Channel and that's how
you can prove that both Network legs
actually belong together and that you
don't didn't get a code substituted
under the covers okay this has exactly
the same purpose as hybrid flow but it's
a considerably easier implementation
yeah because all of the checks happen on
the server that they don't have to be
done on the client side and that's why
more and more people are leaning towards
rather implementing pixie as
implementing hybrid flow these days okay
so because you know all you need to do
on the client is hash something send it
to the server and that's it
right so yeah you need to have one of
the two now which one you prefer
up to you yeah know that the end result
is the same
no hybrid flow I think is most it mostly
designed for server-side applications
with various pixie can be used
everywhere ma'am I think it's in yeah
it's the simpler solution to the problem
okay so just just just to show you
another application which is not written
by me now if you need to convince
someone that this this browser-based
logging thing is actually not too bad
let's get up for desktop you know when
you download that there
if that that if you have this
application on your desktop you probably
also have an existing session already
with get up okay so when you go here to
preferences and say sign-in you see
basically they say sign in using your
browser so what they actually gonna do
is they gonna now launched the default
browser on your machine which holds all
the sessions and the cookies and so on
and then if you are already locked in in
that browser you will directly come back
with tokens that github desktop needs to
talk to the API is that they provide
okay okay now the sign-in experience is
not as nice as it is for example on the
phone you have this dialog now saying
okay I'm done I guess do you want to
come back to the application that
initiated that and I can see that some
people don't like that because maybe a
normal user would be confused what's
going on here right now yeah what you
could do probably is have a nice a page
here saying what's going on and why is
it okay to click the open link or the
open button yeah but they didn't do that
I guess the assumption is developers
know what that means ma'am anyways when
I when I click open it's basically doing
the same thing that the code came back
to the client application and then the
client application cut the tokens and
then they can call the github API ice
okay or if you're building your next
text-based adventure for example yeah
and you need authentication you can also
make that work in a console app right so
all what what this thing is really doing
is it launches again that the default
browser and makes you sign in there okay
so maybe with Google again okay
same same behavior right you want to go
back to whatever windows console system
browser dot XE is but you know we're
developers might make sense and then the
tokens are back into your console app
right and then you can start you know
calling API is like you enter at RK k
for things like that so yeah so it's
it's a general-purpose technique
basically to to rather use the server
rendered login page dinner then a client
rendered login page ok good what is to
say about talking management here well
it's pretty much the same as on the
server right you should store those
token somewhere secure
every operating system has typically
built-in secure data storage mechanism
like heat chain an iOS or DP API on
Windows or there's something on Android
which I don't know the name of you have
to again manage your refresh tokens you
know same idea you keep the Refresh
token somewhere secure if the token
expires you get a new access token by
the Refresh token and you know that's
how the client keeps itself alive and
same idea is at lock out or uninstall
time of the application you probably
should revoke those token for that they
are properly been cleaned up ok so oh
yeah client libraries the the people
that wrote did the spec the RFC date
they have two reference implementations
of that one for iOS one for Android and
their native like written in Java and
objective-c and the one I just showed
you is is a dotnet standard library it's
written in C sharp and it works on
multiple flavors of off the net ok so
now the really the big elephant in the
room here is browser-based applications
because they have some special
considerations okay and that guidance
has recently changed and there's a new
spec here which is basically for has the
same purpose as the OAuth for native
apps they won't have an O or for
browser-based apps and Brock and I have
been working hard for the last weeks to
update course material update the client
libraries update everything to reflect
this new guidance so if the Prok will
show you what is this all about which is
we're doing this thing that you probably
should never do like switching laptops
in the middle of a presentation but you
know we'll see we're professionals
oh right oh good the mics on let's good
start Oh scary okay good excellent
oh no don't do that all right so yeah
the the last type of client application
that we're gonna look at the the notion
of a you know JavaScript browser-based
application and the stomach mentioned
it's the elephant in the room because
it's really the hardest scenario to to
secure the the well and but they are as
it says up there the the most popular
type of application right all the people
building angular apps and you know react
apps and things like that so the reason
it's the one of the hardest scenarios to
secure is because that browser is a
shared execution context right you'll
open up a tab and you go to one
application you open up another tab you
go to another application and they're
sharing the context of that browser so
that makes this actually a really
hostile environment because you could be
in a good app and then in the bad app
the bad app is running code in the
browser and is doing attacks against the
good app these two most common types of
attacks cross-site request forgery and
cross-site scripting and basically these
are both about scenarios where the you
know from outside of your good
application a malicious app is somehow
triggering requests into your good app
the cross-site request forgery is trying
to take advantage of like submitting
data into your application or extracting
data and leveraging the users
authentication session in the you know
the the good application cross-site
scripting is where it from outside you
know code is injected into your
application and both of those obviously
are not good
so as Dominic showed all the the specs
and all the evolutions of the the
specifications around Oh off and an open
ID connect basically what was happening
is you know they would put out one of
those specs it was a like a starting
point for guidance on how to do
something and then somebody would
discover a problem or vulnerability and
they would then put out
to try to fix it or patch it up and so
Dominic mentioned the the best practice
document for native apps mobile mobile
apps so we've been wanting something
like that for a long time for JavaScript
applications and they just would never
you know no one would ever actually you
know take up the charge and actually do
the work involved with writing one of
these documents but finally someone did
that and so they're in the process the
IETF is in the process of updating their
guidance or providing a guidance
document for these JavaScript
browser-based applications so it's it's
sort of been a you know a long time
coming
so before OAuth though right to just
kind of look at a little bit of history
of how we were securing Web API calls
from JavaScript
you know before OAuth which is now eight
or nine years you know the kind of
application that you might have built
that had JavaScript calling api's was
probably more like a server-side
application right I mean I think 10 or
15 years ago I was doing like asp.net
and it was a server rendered application
and then you learned about like jQuery
and you're like wow I can do cool things
in JavaScript and then you know actually
make my page a little bit more
interactive without using like I don't
know the update panel or something like
that
and so the idea is that to get logged
into the application in the first place
you needed a cookie because it was a
server rendered application and so the
beauty about cookies is that if you make
you know JavaScript calls Ajax calls
back to your endpoints the cookie is
automatically sent okay that's beautiful
we loved it because we didn't have to
think about trying to authenticate those
calls so that's basically where the
problem lies is that the cookie is
automatically sent on every request
implicitly by the browser and that's
actually what that cross-site request
forgery attack is taking advantage of
right you open up the bad app and
another tab and they start making
requests across that boundary and the
cookie will be sent and the your good
apps server-side code doesn't know that
which app was making the request
so there are mitigations for this for
the typical server-side application like
your older
asp.net or even you know MVC and beef of
hi for example the ante forgery style
right was the the typical mitigation
against that so it's very easy to add in
and and all the templates have that kind
of built in now for asp.net core as well
even but the problem is most often there
was nothing in the templates or nobody
educated you on how to do it for your
JavaScript calls so if you have the
scenario where you have normal post
backs you're probably protected against
cross-site request forgery but are you
sure that you're protected on all your
Ajax calls okay so very often we we do
code reviews for people and we see that
they're missing it for the Ajax
endpoints okay that's an open problem
okay so like I said this is sort of the
biggest problem with cookies for
authentication is this cross-site
request forgery attacked okay all right
so you know Oh auth was then being
developed as a way to protect api's you
know about nine eight or nine years ago
now and so as part of their whole
guidance around you know how are we
gonna do token-based authentication to
api's they realized oh there's these new
style of apps that are being developed
which are more and more JavaScript
running in the browser and you know less
server-side code okay now some people
didn't you know see this coming right
and this is actually uh from the IETF
archive email archive and somebody was
like oh I don't know what this
JavaScript thing is all about and I
couldn't Google for it but but I'm glad
and I'm you know that the IETF or
somebody on the OAuth working group you
know had the foresight to say hey we
need to secure this new style of
application being developed the problem
is again if you look at the date there
it's just when you know 2011 so that is
what you know nine years ago nine years
ago they had to solve the problem of
figuring out how to allow a JavaScript
application to get a token and call an
API we talked about code flow right code
flow is the the one that we talked about
is the sort of the user
you know interactive application style
to get tokens but the problem with that
is that that requires using the token
endpoint okay and very often your token
server would be on a different domain
than your JavaScript app so we can't
make this cross domain you know Ajax
calls because of browser restrictions
okay so cores didn't exist at that point
in time so basically the token endpoint
as the technique was sort of out of the
question also to use the token endpoint
right we need a client secret and you
know that doesn't really make sense for
a JavaScript style application so what
the OAuth committee came up with is
something called the implicit flow and
the implicit flow is like an optimized
version of the code flow if you will
where we don't have to use the token
endpoint it's a way to get a token back
to a front-end application and so the
way it would work is that your
JavaScript application would be running
in the browser you would send the user
to the authorized endpoint I know if you
notice down here but the request is now
requesting ID token token as opposed to
a code okay
that's basically saying I want two token
directly back from the token server and
that's exactly what would happen then in
this implicit flow the response would
come back into the browser the tokens
that you're looking for are being sent
in the URL
okay and they're being sent after this
hash fragment in in the URL there and
you know the ultimate destination for
the token is the JavaScript right so
that makes sense we have to hand it
somehow back to the JavaScript and again
this avoids using the token endpoint so
the app doesn't have to make you the
Ajax calls back to the token server to
get tokens okay so that is still
officially you know technically the
official guidance on how you would write
JavaScript apps to obtain tokens to call
api's but as we saw with the sort of the
the charge with all the specs across all
the years right the guidance changes
over time and that's because we you know
get more and more features out of things
like our browsers and more and more
technologies get developed to help make
things like this better you know to
really do this right there are a few
problems right one is that one of the
biggest complaints is that the token is
in the URL okay now that's why the hash
fragment
is used because we don't send those to
the server assuming the browsers
actually implement that properly it's in
your you know your history and you know
maybe somebody hits the back arrow and
then can see the access token so there
are things you could try to do to fix it
up but it wasn't wasn't part of the
protocol you as the application
developer had to know to go do these
extra things and it's a bit of work okay
so and also of course if you're using to
deal with this token substitution attack
right we could do open ID connect and do
ID token and token but if you're doing
just pure ooofff again we didn't have
any subset of protection against the
token substitution attack okay so anyway
that has been the biggest complaint
about the implicit flow really since it
was invented right tokens in the URL but
at the same time it's the best we had
given the limitations so what is then
sort of the the guidance going forward
well the things that have been developed
since the original recommendation
basically is that cores has been
developed right now pretty much browsers
all support cores so now we could take
advantage of the token endpoint and
Dominic talked about this new thing
called pixie and pixie helps with the
code substitution attack so with the you
know development of those two features
if you will over the last several years
it's basically put us in a position
where we now can do better than what we
did before with the implicit flow so the
new guidance that will be coming out
from the IETF is basically for spa's
JavaScript applications you should be
using authorization code flow with pixie
okay and that's basically the new guide
that's going forward so it's not that
the implicit flow is awful and horrible
it's just that we now have a better
solution so if you've been doing
implicit flow for the last several years
that's fine okay but you know if you
have token server that supports these
new things then great maybe you could
switch over and start start using them
okay
so regardless of whichever those flows
you end up using we come back to the
same you know complications that the
other types of clients have to contend
which is you know the token management
where do you store the token and how do
you deal with token renewal and how do
you protect against attacks against
those things so the I guess for
browser-based applications this is also
why they're kind of a difficult
environment to protect is that they have
no fundamental safe storage if you will
no protected storage like you do on us
well obviously on a server side but also
in sort of these native apps so you have
to store the token somewhere right so
the common locations are to put the
token in session storage local storage
maybe indexdb but usually those are the
first two that I said are the ones where
we usually see session storage or local
storage so of course the big problem
here is that your app is still prone to
cross-site scripting attacks right and
not only your app but your entire domain
so not maybe your apps on a you know
some path under your domain but you have
some other part of your app that has
cross-site scripting right so that's a
very large surface to protect against so
cross-site scripting is really the real
biggest concern with building spas it's
not Olaf and all this stuff okay
so again if you do have a cross-site
scripting attack somewhere in your app
and it can access that storage an
attacker can export the tokens from your
app okay so how do we protect against
this okay well there is yet another
newer feature in browsers that we can
start to take advantage of to help with
this and it's something called content
security policy this is a feature of
browsers that allow you to tell your
browser that you want to reduce how much
JavaScript you'll allow to run ok and
basically kind of boils down to where
you say I want this block of Travie
script I'm gonna like whitelist and
allow it to run on my browser and other
sources by default are going to be
disabled ok so if you're building a
JavaScript application you really should
be you know leveraging content security
policy
turns out it's really hard though okay
because if you especially if you not
built the app designed around content
security policy you know depending on
the size and complexity of your app it's
really really hard to retrofit so
there's actually a link down here at the
bottom to a video from a couple of
researchers from Google I believe it's
what they're from and they basically did
an analysis on all the websites and how
many out there actually use CSP and for
the ones that did UCSB and by the way
the number was really small and the ones
that did use CSP how many were actually
had holes in their CSP policies and one
of the common things is that you know
people will you see the ends for their
JavaScript and so very often with a
content security policy you can just
whitelist an entire CDN and say oh yeah
that's where my code runs right that's
where I want to cache from so let it you
know let it run on my browser well the
problem is the CDN is also a shared
environment and lots of other people are
running all kinds of other code up on
the CDN so that's you know probably not
the best approach
okay so content security policy is
something you should be using
but again admittedly it's it's really
hard there's another specification that
was intended to help fix some of these
problems as well and it's all called
HTTP token binding and the idea with
HTTP token binding is that you want to
make sure that the token can only be
used within the app that was obtaining
the token okay and so this is like
really promising because then imagine
you know you have an app and somehow the
cross site scripting steals the access
token and now the attacker if they've
exported and are trying to use it from
some of the location they can't if this
HTTP token binding thing ensured that
the token could only be used from that
particular browser for example okay so
this is actually really promising to
solve a lot of problems you know now
that we're talking about using code flow
from a JavaScript app we also think
about getting potentially refresh tokens
right think of refresh tokens are lost
from your app those are even more
powerful than access tokens because they
can just continue to get new access
tokens over and over and over
and it's you know outside your browser
so refresh tokens in this mode are still
very very dangerous to do so anyway this
HTTP token binding sounded like it was
going to be the solution to the problem
because it really restricted who could
be actually using the token and then
unfortunately I think it was the same
month that the token binding specs were
actually finished Google announced that
they were removing token binding as a
feature from chrome okay why it's not
terribly clear they didn't seem to
understand the benefit of it and it was
actually in Chrome and then they removed
it so not entirely sure why and I've
never seen any justification really
since then explaining it but even other
people in Google who work on these specs
are trying to you know say please let's
get it back in yeah question
I think there are they working on it
yeah yeah so anyway yeah so
unfortunately I think because one of the
major browser vendors removed it it
means we can't really rely upon it right
unfortunately so anyway that's kind of a
bummer as we say in the u.s. right okay
so anyway yeah this is again the cold
cross-site scripting and you know it's a
hard problem ok now the other thing that
we need to talk about in terms of like
managing a token is the token renewal
and we talked about you know maybe
refresh tokens aren't the best approach
in these JavaScript apps because of how
dangerous they are in that context if
they're stolen so the other approach is
this thing called a silent renew and
that's been around for as a technique
for a really long time for JavaScript
applications which is basically you make
the same authorization request back to
the token server to get a new token
except you do it in an iframe all right
that way the user won't see it that also
has the characteristic of the iframe is
relying upon the cookie the session at
the token server
so that means that only somebody with
that valid session or cookie can
actually continue to get new access
tokens so that's actually a nice
technique to restrict access you know
and ensure only that JavaScript app is
the legitimate one to continue to get
new tokens okay okay so we have a
JavaScript library that implements these
protocols we've had this now for several
years and it was just around the end of
last year where we have updated it to
now support code flow with pixee okay so
I have a quick sample of that maybe not
the most beautiful thing in the world
there we go so I have this little
JavaScript application what I have here
is an HTML page ok it is loading in our
you know o ID c client javascript
library and the idea is that we go off
and you know do our normal configuration
as a client and the big thing here is
the response type years code okay so you
might have been using this library
before to do implicit flow really not a
big deal you just update to the latest
version and switch your response type
right instead of ID token token which
was the implicit flow you can switch
over to code and that's pretty much what
you need to do to get your app to do
this this new flow okay and then what we
have is this user manager which can do a
little bit of session management for you
and do the protocol work the session
management is provided by a little get
user function that can load up and see
if the users you know has a session in
your app and some helpers log in and log
out right to go do the the protocol work
and so simply logging in I have an
internet connection good there's my
token server Bob and Bob and here we go
we got the results and we came back and
maybe I guess I should have shown that
on the network but if we rerun this yeah
somewhere in here we should see the word
token right so the point is we were in
fact using the token endpoint from the
client and somewhere way down here we
should see a code the
sent along okay so this is an updated
app to use code flow with pixee
and by the way there's the code verifier
for pixie so now we can invoke our API
which is just a matter of loading up the
session getting the user object getting
the access token and calling that API
the renewal like I talked about then
supports the ability to renew your
tokens but it does it in the iframe okay
so if you hit renew token I don't know
if you can see down here at the bottom
but what we're doing is the the library
is simply you know crafting up the
iframe making the request and getting
the result back okay good
all right now there's actually one more
topic here in the space of our
JavaScript applications as we've already
mentioned there are all these new specs
that are coming out to help with all
these features and then some vendors
decide not to implement them that's a
different issue but one other one is
something called same site cookies okay
do you remember the the original problem
with our original design of JavaScript
apps using cookies to do authentication
was the cross-site request forgery
attack okay
and we needed to do all kinds of
mitigations to protect against that so
it turns out that that's exactly what
same site cookies is for it's a new spec
from the w3c it basically extends of the
features of how cookies work with this
new flag called same site so the idea
now is that when you render your cookie
or you issue a cookie back to the
browser you can append a same site flag
and this tells the browser that the
cookie should only be sent back to your
app or your API if the page making the
request is from the same site okay that
effectively kills the attack of
cross-site request forgery okay the
biggest concern with this of course is
that it's a fairly new feature okay so
it's just in the last six months that
we're actually kind of getting all the
latest browsers caught up with
implementing this but you still have you
know maybe you have many people running
on the prior version of browsers so you
know whether or not you want to start
pending on this is sort of up to you
Dominic is still a little gun-shy of it
that's a good point too yeah the spec is
not finalized yet so but I'm very
confident in this so okay so many went
that's the idea what this means is then
Wow maybe we don't need tokens for
protecting our web api's okay
now that's only gonna work if your
application is the same site application
right the cookies only going back to the
same site but what if you have API is
that our cross-domain still but you want
to use the same site cookie well there's
a very typical architecture here which
is this BFF architecture right it stands
for back-end for front-end so this
actually kind of looks like what we
might have done 10 or 15 years ago so
imagine what you're gonna do is you're
not gonna have your spa connect directly
to the web api okay what you'll have is
you'll have a back-end right piece of
your application that will go and do the
normal login workflows with OAuth and
open ID connect right you'll get back
your tokens and then you'll issue cookie
in your browser and all of the calls
from your JavaScript are gonna go back
to your server your your you know your
back-end for your front-end if you will
using the cookie style right with our
same site cookies okay and then the
backend because we have a cookie and we
logged in with open ID connected OAuth
we can then have our proper access
tokens to then call back to the
underlying API so that's another style
that you could use I think we have a lot
of people who are interested in this
style because if you think about you
know all of this JavaScript that you
have to write in your application you're
really increasing the complexity in your
spa so I think that's you know depends
on your architecture depends if you want
the spa to go directly to the API or if
it's you know you'd rather deal with
sort of the lesser of the two evils
right in terms of securing the
JavaScript from things like you know our
various attacks it might be a little bit
easier if we have this style okay so
it's another option
and so actually have a demo of this yeah
go ahead yep
so the HTTP only flag is a flag it's
been around forever as far as I could
remember in cookies and it basically is
the flag to tell the browser that you
don't want the cookie programmatically
available from JavaScript which in
effect you're relying upon the browser
to protect you from like the cross-site
scripting attack at least of stealing
the cookie it's kind of like the st. you
know the the token binding the HTTP
binding that we were talking about
before okay so we have a sample here let
me run this which is now different HTML
oh that's not what I wanted let me go
run my API so what I have here is
another example I have two projects in
my solution here the first one is
basically a standalone API this is the
API that's meant to be the API on the
far right on the slide and this is an
API that is only gonna receive access
tokens okay so I have this running which
I think I have it running okay and then
over here in my host this is now the
application that has a combination of
some the backend for front-end if you
will right so we're gonna do normal open
ID connect over to our token server but
we're gonna then have some endpoints in
here that are going to be protected for
using cookies okay those are going to be
invoked by our Ajax code and those will
do something like maybe just be the
features the the api's that are needed
to serve up to our front end okay but
you may have again some features that
can be implemented at this point and
some features that actually need to be
sent all the way depending on what you
know type of API you need to call so you
need something else in this back-end for
front-end to produce things like proxy
right basically proxy the the requests
all the way over so there's another
piece in here which is a
open-source project called proxy kit I
believe it basically allows you to run a
reverse proxy as middleware in your
asp.net core application so the idea is
that maybe some endpoints go just to my
BFF other endpoints go to these proxy
endpoints and they get proxied over to
the to the actual API when I'm doing the
proxying from the browser to my BFF is
using the cookie and then when we hit
this particular reverse proxy notice
it's actually extracting the access
token from my cookie and then you know
using that to call to the actual
back-end so that's basically if I rerun
this that's basically what this is doing
so log in with a Bob and Bob okay so
this first button here basically when I
invoke this this is just going one hop
right to the to the first API call and
this is then simply using my you know my
BFF cookie that I have okay this just
happens to be hitting a different path
in the application which actually then
routes all the way over to the other guy
and that's using the access token and
you can see then the return here is
actually showing you everything that was
in the access token so again for the
first hop same idea is using the cookie
but for the second hop it's using the
access token so there's a sample
application that shows you you know how
that approach could work okay so here's
a list of lots of reading right this is
homework for you now that we've come to
class for an hour you can go home and
read up on all these sort of latest and
greatest things from the spec committees
and all these other things from you know
the w3c so that's there for you and
other than that oh we have some stickers
if you'd like some identity server
stickers but other than that that's it
thanks
[Applause]